hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe I'm your
host Sean Carroll and today's big idea
is space time that should come as no
surprise for those of you who are fans
are the biggest ideas we did space and
then we did time so now we're gonna do
space time and you might want to know
well why does this count as a separate
big idea if we already did space and
time
of course secretly space time not so
secretly is about relativity and in
particular while we'll be concentrating
on today is special relativity Einstein
came up with two versions of relativity
special in general will mention general
relativity which is the theory of curved
space time and gravity but today we're
just gonna be focusing on what is
space-time itself what why do you need
an idea called space-time if you've
already had space and you've already had
time and I should say that as usual I'll
be taking a slightly idiosyncratic point
of view on the whole thing this is not a
traditional course we're not going
through in order all the big ideas like
either a course or a history lesson what
we're trying to do is to get at some
aspects of these ideas in an interesting
and new way so usually when you're
introduced to space-time were to
relativity there's a certain bottom-up
approach in the sense that we start with
ideas from Newtonian physics which
includes absolute space absolute time
and this is you know this is how we
think this is how we intuitively think
about the world that there's space and
there's time and they're kind of very
very different and then we show that
through a bunch of arguments about
symmetries and the speed of light and so
forth you end up with space-time and
special relativity so therefore since
you might have been introduced to that
way of doing it before I'm gonna be
doing the other way I'm gonna is gonna
be giving you the basic ideas of
space-time from the top down and then we
can show how those basic ideas recover
our ordinary Newtonian intuitions and
it's not that one way is better than the
other I was actually just talking very
recently with some colleagues of mine at
Caltech about the best way to teach
special relativity and there's
definitely this difference between
top-down and bottom-up approaches
different people will learn better from
different approaches so there's no right
one but this is mine this is what I'm
gonna do today so Newton
would have told you that there was
absolute space he might not have used
these words maybe he deduced these words
I'm not quite sure an absolute time by
which we mean when you say something
like what time is it right now at Alpha
Centauri 4 light-years away in Newtonian
physics there's an answer to that
there's an answer to the question what
time is it at every single event in the
universe whereas if you want to say
where something is you also get an
answer to that but they don't mix
together in any meaningful way
so Einstein and in fact not even
Einstein so much as his former teacher
Minkowski or Minkowski if we're being
German about it invented this
four-dimensional space-time and of
course it works equally well in higher
numbers of dimensions as we talked about
when we talked about space and why why
do you have to do that why do you have
to say forget about space and time
separately think about four-dimensional
space-time it's because the division of
space-time into space and time
separately still have not a bill the
ability to talk and write at the same
time you're allowed to do it right
you're allowed to say okay here's what
I'm gonna slice --is that I'm gonna cut
through space-time to define one moment
of time I'm gonna call that space but
the point is the way you do that is not
fixed by nature it is not something that
is built in to the fabric of the
universe it is a human convention it is
something that you decide do you for
your convenience
you're gonna divide up space-time into
space and time in a particular way this
does not mean it's wrong to do it okay
this idea of a human being coming along
and deciding to simplify or
conceptualize something in a certain way
that is very convenient doesn't mean
it's wrong it's a very convenient way of
doing it I mean when we go through our
lives we're not going to talk
relativistically for reasons we will
explain but the
you shouldn't become too wedded to it
especially if you're trying to
understand fundamental physics so that's
basically why we have to talk about
space-time we'll get into more details
obviously later but the other thing is
how should we understand it and I have a
very simple motto for how you should
think about space-time space-time is
kind of like space what I mean by that
well there's a whole bunch of puzzles
right and if you've ever been exposed to
special relativity at all you I have all
these paradoxes you're taught and you
know hurts your brain to figure out how
to answer them in my opinion essentially
all these paradoxes go away if you
really think about space-time as a
universal thing in other words if you
take this top-down approach start with
space-time and then ask all your
questions rather than trying to shoehorn
relativistic situations into old
fashioned Newtonian intuition we have
intuition about space we need to extend
that intuition about space to all of
space-time and that will make our lives
much easier so let me show you this in
action
consider the idea of the distance
between two points now you might think
that's a perfectly well-defined idea in
space so let's do space and contrast it
with space-time I mean I should say in
case it's not perfectly obvious the
definition of space-time is just the set
of points in space and time so the set
of events as we call them located with
three numbers which are your locations
in the three dimensions of space and a
fourth number which is your moment of
time so it's a four dimensional manifold
we would say a four dimensional space in
the notion of space that mathematicians
use but the point is is more than that
there's structure there's mathematical
facts about space-time that come in to
how it actually works out so that's what
we're actually gonna be exploring in
this talk so in space I'll draw space
and
you might have coordinates right so
here's an x-coordinate here's a
y-coordinate it doesn't matter how we
label them or how we draw them or
whatever and you might have points
here's point a here's point B I want to
get from point A to point B what is the
distance between them well you could
draw the straight line connecting them
and calculate the distance that's
something that you could do you could
even use Pythagoras theorem if you
wanted to however that's the distance
you would that's that is only the
distance you would actually Traverse
while walking from point A to point B if
you took of the straight line path no
one is surprised to learn that if you
take some other path then your distance
is different right the distance you
actually Traverse along a path is
different than the shortest distance
path distance between those two points
this is so obvious that it's hard even
to say people who have a little a
domitor right where who are measuring
how far they walk or I guess a Fitbit or
something like that right they will get
different answers walking between the
same exact two points if they take
different paths that's just again so
obvious that we internalize it the
distance depends on the path so our
motto is space time is kind of like
space and in exactly the same way the
time elapsed between two events in space
time is going to depend on the path so
in space time the picture is gonna look
very very similar except this is now all
of space so it's X but also Y etc and
this vertical Direction is what we label
as time okay and then rather than a
location in space you have an event a an
event B so the event a is both a
location space and a moment of time and
you can travel between a and B that is
not surprising and you could travel on a
straight line which would be a constant
velocity through space okay and then you
could figure out well what is the
space-time equivalent of the distance
that we walked when we were just talking
about space because now we're moving
through both space and time right we're
moving through
X and we're moving through T in a sort
of space and time separately way of
talking about it well the actual the
answer is that rather than bringing in a
domitor along with you walking through
space when you bring here as a clock you
measure the amount of time elapsed along
the path then you might say well why do
I even need to do that I could just
figure out what time I left and what
time I arrived and that's the time that
is elapsed but the whole point of space
time is no that is not the time that is
elapsed the time that your clock
measures along a path is not the same as
the coordinate time that you define
throughout the universe exactly as over
in our little picture of space the
distance you travel is not equal to X or
to Y when you're traveling along some
diagonal path so when you travel along
some different path through space-time
the duration the amount of time elapsed
depends on the path that you take this
surprises us this is not what we're used
to thinking about if you know if we
synchronize our watches and what we're
doing at pulling off a good spy caper we
expect that if we meet up later even
though we've taken different paths
through space time our watches will
still be synchronized if they're good
watches as we'll see in a moment that's
because we're all moving very slowly
compared to the speed of light but this
is the insight that makes space-time
kind of like space the time elapsed
along trajectories of objects moving
slower than the speed of light people
particles rocket ships whatever is
analogous to the distance along a path
okay so what this means is time is not
absolute Newton was not correct about
that
time is something that different people
measure one might almost say it is
relative to the person moving and what
their clock reads that's where the word
relativity comes from that is one way in
which it comes about the time coordinate
which is something Universal we invented
it we put it on space time we put
coordinates on the universe but the
point is it's not equal to the elapsed
duration for any particular observer it
might be by coincidence
equal for some observers but it is not
fundamentally the same kind of thing so
that's interesting but of course we know
that space time is not exactly the same
as space right it's not quite the saying
that there's there's clearly some
differences you know one difference
we've already talked about which is that
if I have an object here it exists in
both space right and left in this way
and it is exist in time it is now and
now and now but there's a difference in
how it exists because there's a
continuity through time right you mean
the pen the pencil the Apple pencil
still exists in more or less the same
form from moment to moment in time but
if you go in space it exists and exists
exists then it stops existing very
dramatically and no one is surprised by
that it would be very dramatic indeed if
the pen just disappeared so where is
that coming from where is that
difference coming from the answer is
that there is a difference between space
time and time namely well one way it
shows up let's we'll get into the
details later namely that for a straight
line in space we all know that in space
a straight line is the shortest distance
path shortest issed that's not good
shortest distance but in space time
the straight-line is the longest
duration right now I'm just asserting
this you're gonna believe me because of
the I'm the authority figure here we'll
explain it a little bit better in just a
second but when you go back to this
picture and you say okay in the
space-time picture when I was going on a
straight line I said that will be a
certain amount of time elapsed if I
carry along my wristwatch on the curvy
line and there'll be a different amount
of time elapsed the rule is on the curvy
line on the line where you are moving in
some complicated way through both space
and time that means you're not moving on
a straight line you will always
experience less time if you move more in
space between the same amount of same
two points you will move less in time so
it's a bit of a trade-off there right I
mean there's no such thing in space
space if you move more and X move more
and why it doesn't really matter but
there's a trade-off in space time the
more you move in space the less you move
in time and we can make that a little
bit more we can put that in a context
maybe you're more familiar with the
famous twin paradox I'm gonna put
paradox in quotes because this is
clearly not a paradox is just a feature
of the universe that is surprising to
you that's not that is not what
qualifies as a paradox the twin paradox
says okay here's our space time again so
this is space this is time and you have
a twin two twins that's what makes them
twins they both start here one of them
just stays home doesn't really move and
evolves from A to B okay this is lazy
twin they sit in their armchair this
twin hops off in a rocket ship goes off
very very fast here's the rocket ship
and then they accelerate so they can go
backwards they can reunite with their
friend they left behind with their twin
that they left behind not the best
rocket ship I've ever drawn sorry about
that
okay these are two people who
synchronize their watches they started
cuz they were born at the same time at
Point a
they left one just when in a straight
line in space-time one when in a curved
line in space-time so the rule is this
one will always have experienced less
time than this then between who stayed
behind so this is where it becomes
purportedly a paradox although it's
clearly not a paradox it's just that
there's no reason for these two people
who went on different paths through
space-time to experience the same amount
of time time is not universal time is
not absolute now I wanted to mention
this in particular even though you've
probably seen it before because it's a
little bit misunderstood what is going
on here so some people say I don't
understand you're telling me that
there's relativity there's symmetry
between motion in different ways one
twin stays stationary and from their
point of view the other twin moves out
and comes back but from the moving twins
perspective from the perspective of the
twin on the rocket their twin moved out
and came back right so isn't there
symmetry between them shouldn't the
amount of time be the same by the
principles of relativity hopefully if
you've been following along you know
that's not right when we talked about
force we mentioned that there is a
difference between inertial trajectories
and non inertial trajectories so there
is a difference between trajectories
that are accelerated in some way and
trajectories that are not accelerated in
some way so there is no symmetry between
these two twins because one twin is
never accelerated and the other twin is
that makes a difference in the physics
of the situation whether or not you're
accelerated matters however it would be
wrong to say glibly that all of the
difference in time between in the time
elapsed for twin 1 and twin 2 is because
of the acceleration what matters is the
distance along the path the space-time
distance the interval along the path you
could imagine a new let me pick a
different color to draw it in so let's
imagine new trajectory those like this
staying home then very quickly
accelerating and accelerating back and
then just staying home again ok that
might not be the brightest color that I
could have picked let me do it this way
there we go okay here's a new trajectory
the periods of acceleration on this
trajectory are exactly the same you
accelerate at the beginning when you
start your journey you accelerate when
you turn around and you accelerate at
the end they just happen at different
times okay but the amount of elapsed
time along this green trajectory and
this original white trajectory here are
going to be completely different the
length of these two pads in space-time
is very different even Richard Fineman
got this wrong when he explained it I'm
sure if you had drawn these two pictures
for him he would have understood it
instantly but he did make the claim that
was the acceleration that accounted for
the difference in time it's not the
acceleration it's the total amount of
path distance that you travel you can't
have a different path distance unless
you accelerate at some point but the
acceleration themselves is not the point
you need to put it together in a
particular way okay so that's the twin
paradox now let's dig a little bit more
deeply into why why is this difference
between space and space-time coming into
the fore the answer is it's the
difference between Euclid Euclidian
geometry or in fact Pythagoras you know
Pythagoras's theorem the square of the
hypotenuse is the sum of the squares the
opposite two sides of a right triangle
this is part of Euclidean geometry okay
and you could lay down these rules for
what you might think of as tabletop
geometry the two-dimensional or even
three-dimensional geometry of ordinary
flat space okay what we're doing in
space-time is replacing the geometry
even though it's still flat in a way
which we'll talk about in more detail
later but it's a different kind of space
a spacetime in fact and this is where
Minkowski comes in it's amusing I think
I've already said this maybe even in
these videos but Einstein didn't like
the idea that special relativity should
be thought of in terms of
four-dimensional space-time this idea
was first proposed by Minkowski and
Minkowski headband Einsteins teacher you
know when he was in school but of course
eventually he needed to Einstein updated
his priors because he realizes a
really helpful way of thinking about
things Einstein thought it was just
extra obtrusive Mattox
sometimes things are extra of couse
mathematics that don't really give any
physical insight but Minkowski and
geometry absolutely is necessary so
let's be a little bit more detailed
about this in space okay space here is
Euclid again x and y okay and what you
know is that if you have two points
connected by a straight line then what
you can do if there's a distance D
between those two points you can figure
out what D is in terms of these
coordinates by saying well here's the
change in X there's the change in Y and
Pythagoras tells us that d squared is x
squared plus y squared it's a right
triangle okay that is sort of one of the
foundation the pillars the building
blocks of Euclidean geometry now over
here in space-time
professor Minkowski is going to give us
a different formula he's going to modify
Pythagoras's theorem so here is space
XYZ etc here's time here are two events
a and B and they're separated and what
we want to do is figure out not the
distance between them but the time
elapsed okay so we do a very similar
thing called the time elapsed tau
because we've already used T for a
coordinate sorry about that we already
use D so we can't call it duration but
here is X and here's T and Minkowski
gives us a formula but the formula is
slightly different than Pythagoras's the
formula is tau squared equals T squared
minus x squared and that minus sign
makes all the difference in the world so
this tau just be SuperDuper clear here
this is the time elapsed measured by
someone who will be moving along that
trajectory between the two points this T
here is the time coordinate and this is
part of the essence of relativity to
separate these two things
in Newtonian physics time was absolute
the time coordinate and the time lapse
are the same what your clock reads no
matter where you do where you go through
the universe is going to be a universal
time coordinate whereas relativity
separates them and says the times more
like space we can choose coordinates
differently you know in space over here
we drew an x-coordinate and a
y-coordinate but we could have drawn
different x coordinates and Y
coordinates right we could have rotated
our axes so that this was X prime this
was Y prime and the point is just that
the coordinates are not special the
coordinates are not fundamental those
are not what really matters they are
human conveniences ways to label where
you are in space but they are not built
into the essence of space itself
likewise T what you and I called the
time coordinate of the universe for
cosmologists we say oh yes this galaxy
was formed when the universe was three
billion years old or something like that
that is a human convenience that is a
coordinate that we put on the universe
it is not necessarily the time elapsed
as seen by an observer so what you see
because of this difference here is that
in space okay with this formula
Pythagoras is formula the more you move
in any direction yours adding more and
more to the total amount of distance
that you travel between these two points
whereas in time there's a in space time
there's a competition the more you move
in X the less time you will actually
experience that is why the twin that
moves off and comes back ages less
because they go on what is ultimately a
shorter amount of interval in space-time
because of this minus sign the more you
move in space the less time you
experience compared to someone who's not
moving at all so that's cool that's fun
and this this is you know fraught with
meaning here because of course this is
the foundation of talking about space
and time in terms of geometry which will
become crucial when we talk about
general relativity and curved geometries
but for right now it's it's kind of a
interesting insight into why things are
this way let me mention a little
consequence of this insight that namely
that some paths if there's this
confident if there's this um
give-and-take right there's this I don't
want say conflict but it's the time and
space had different signs when they come
into this interval that we calculated
they can competition is the word I'm
looking for some pads will have zero
time elapsed along them so you can
compete so much that you don't
experience time at all so here is again
X T and if you go on what we've been
would draw as a 45-degree angle actually
let me not let me draw that as just a
straight line okay and this I'll make
the dashed lines so now you have a
certain amount of interval X a certain
amount of interval T and tau along this
45 degree line while tau squared equals
T squared minus x squared so if x equals
T tell the amount of time elapsed equals
zero I'm you know biting my tongue here
of course because there are things that
actually do move this way in space-time
we call them rays of light or photons or
for that matter gravitons or other
massless particles in the universe this
kind of thing is exactly what light does
and this is wide light beams or photons
do not experience the passage of time
from their local point of view from
there if a photon could have a clock it
wouldn't tick it would just remain
frozen because there would be nothing
happening but before we get into the
details of that I have to sort of
explain something that I've been that I
sort of hid and maybe you noticed maybe
you didn't depending on how closely
you're paying attention when you say
things like if x equals T okay there's
an obvious problem with that relation
X
is measured in something like meters T
is measured in something like seconds
you can choose different units if you
want but the point is no choice of Units
make space and time be measured in the
same units they're different things so
if you're good at dimensional analysis
not in the sense of the dimensions of
space-time but in the sense of the units
that we use to quantify physical
quantities you would know that a
equation like x equals T is just
nonsense or even an equation like cao
squared equals T squared minus x squared
nonsense you can't add quantities that
are defined using different units so
what's going on why would I fool you in
such a terrible way well the answer is
there is a built in speed there is a
speed we call it C and it is equal to
300 million meters per second or in much
more convenient units one light year per
year what happened there I don't know so
this is the new feature that space-time
has that space doesn't if you're going
to combine space and time in some way
you need a way to convert them back and
forth to each other the way you do that
how do you take something that is time
and turn it into space well you multiply
it by space divided by time right time
times space divided by time equals space
and space divided by time is a velocity
and this see the speed of light 300
million meters per second or one light
year per year that is it is 300 million
light years per second right is 300,000
kilometers per second therefore 300
million meters per second yes C is the
velocity that is the cool
version factor between space and time so
it happens to be a fact that light moves
at the speed of light but from the
relativity point of view that's not what
matters about the speed of light did
they mean the fact that light happens to
move there is you know interesting and
important for understanding light but we
could easily imagine a world where
relativity was still real and nothing
moved at the speed of light it would
just be a limit it would be this
speed up to which you could never reach
in this fake world where nothing was a
massless object moving at the speed of
light but there is still be the built-in
speed limit the conversion factor that
told you how to relate space and time
that's what the speed of light really is
we're gonna keep calling at the speed of
light because that's what we call it but
it is really the built-in speed limit
that characterizes the conversion
between space and time in Minkowski and
geometry and there the rules are speed
of light the speed of light is a limit
it is the an absolute universal speed
limit every one observes it if you try
to accelerate up to the speed of light
and then Beyond it turns out it would
take an infinite amount of energy you're
not gonna do that it's not going to
happen
particles that you know and love or
objects that are made of many particles
will never move faster than the speed of
light and furthermore not only is it a
speed limit but it is invariant oops
in other words it looks the same to
everyone this is the thing that gets a
little bit tricky when you try to
conceptualize it if you are on a train
and you're moving at 30 miles an hour
and you throw a ball forward at 10 miles
an hour from the point of view of
someone on the road watching the train
go by the ball looks like it's going at
40 miles an hour 30 plus 10 okay the
velocities just add whereas if you have
a flashlight on the train and you point
it in some direction
the speed of light that you measure is
exactly equal to the speed of light that
was measured by someone on the street
they do not add together there's a more
complicated way in which you combine
velocities and relativity so that the
speed of light is the same
to absolutely everyone which makes sense
it's built into the fabric of space-time
there's no preferred trajectories in
space-time so if you're on a train
you're on a rocket if you're on the
ground as long as you're not
accelerating to you spacetime looks the
same and that means the speed of light
looks the same and what that means is
that there is a feature of space-time
called light cones so if we draw this is
my favorite part
so if we draw our space-time diagram X
and T and you have some point here okay
and you measure X in lightyears and you
measure T in years then starting from
this point light will move out at
45-degree angles into the future whether
it goes left or right I'm only drawing
one dimension of space but of course
really there's more dimensions of space
so what I can do is sort of complete
this into a cone describing the interior
of the cone as all the points you can
reach going slower than the speed of
light okay so we do so this is light
moving at 45 degrees this line that I
drew is a massive particle massive
particles move slower than the speed of
light and this whole light cone that
I've drawn is basically you start at the
event you imagine doesn't have to be
real but you imagine sending out rays of
light in every direction they move
through space-time and every real
particle has to go at that speed or
slower so the number of points the set
of all points you can reach like
starting at one event and going into the
future is the future and it takes the
form of this cone that is the light cone
there's also a past light cone you can
imagine all the beams of light that came
to you from the past and again there's
more dimensions of space so we fill in
the diagram and this is the set of
points which you would call your past so
this is where the rubber hits the road
in terms of the difference between
space-time and Newtonian absolute space
and absolute
for Newton there was the future there
was the past and then there was now
there was simultaneity so I'll draw this
smaller diagram Newton you can still
draw space-time diagrams in Newtonian
physics space and then if you're a point
right here this is what the diagram
looks like future past now okay whereas
the Minkowski your Einsteinian diagram
has this cone structure where there's
the future
there's the past and then there's a set
of points which we simply call space
like a set of space like separated
events in space-time and you want to say
well are those points you know as an
event right here is that happening at
the same time as the event there you're
just not allowed to ask that question
that's just not well formed thing to say
in relativity and and you'll emphasize
that a little bit more there's no so
there's no absolute notion of
simultaneity but there is instead what
it's replaced by is the structure of
dividing all of space-time into three
regions from any one point that the
point has a future like oh and a past
light cone and a set of space like
separated points where you can't get to
without going faster than the speed of
light in some sense that's what replaces
the notion of now but it's obviously a
lot bigger than the notion of now in
Newtonian mechanics so you might you
might ask a perfectly good thing to ask
when faced with this kind of picture is
why don't we notice why isn't that
completely obvious to us why do we think
that there is something called now right
why why did Newton who is a pretty smart
cookie not draw these light cones I mean
by the way actually let me draw up
something first to be a little bit more
yeah the reason why this was my favorite
part is because it's the light cones
that are really the true structure in
space-time so I don't wanna this is such
a pretty picture I don't want to redraw
I'll just redraw it again I don't want
to erase it I'll just redraw it again
we've been drawing space-time diagrams
like this there's space there's time and
then you say okay here's a point a an
event and there's light cones going into
the future and coming in from the past
okay and every point has a light cone
here's B okay and the light cones by the
way continue on eyes don't draw them but
they don't end they go on infinitely far
into the past and future and from point
B there's also light cones going out
let again it's the same idea it's just a
set of points that you can reach going
at or slower than the speed of light
okay and you can extend these into the
future so when you have two points you
can talk about a region up here that is
in the future of both of them a region
down here that is in the past of both of
them and everything else is neither in
the past or future of both of them
simultaneously
but the point is these light cones are
the real structure built into space-time
if you in my dream world of perfect
physics which is not even a dream world
I want to become true but if let's put
it this way if the right way to teach
physics was just to start with the
absolute truth and laid on everyone
rather than to build it up gradually
right by going from Newtonian mechanics
to relativity to quantum mechanics if
you just started with the truth at the
top and then explained how it actually
matched on to our experience you would
never draw the time coordinate and the
spacecraft coordinate because those
things are not built into the fabric of
space-time those are human choices the
things that are built in are the light
comes the light cones are the real thing
that defines how space-time goes sadly
that's never gonna happen and probably
it shouldn't happen it would be like to
to divorce from our everyday experience
to make much pedagogical sense but that
is how space-time actually works okay
that's the that's the other thing when
to say but now we can read ress this
question I was just about to say why
don't we notice why don't we think that
way why is it hard for us to imagine
that that's how space-time really is
well the answer is when
I drew this picture here I was careful
to show to indicate this was X measured
in lightyears this was t measured in
years a year is not so long the
experience years but a light year is
really a lot of far distance for us
right most of us will not travel a light
year in our lives the nearest star is 4
light years away so why don't we notice
well it's because when we actually in
our lives would draw space-time diagrams
it were we to do that and we measured
space and time in more reasonable human
units let's say X was measured in meters
T was measured in seconds and then you
have an event you can still draw the
light cones right but the light cones
are not at 45 degrees if this is you
know 1 meter 2 meters 3 meters and this
is 0 1 second 2 seconds 3 seconds 1 you
remember the speed of light is 300
million meters per second so one second
later starting from here I should be at
x equals 300 million I can't even
possibly draw that right my my dashed
line would be very very close to just a
perfect horizontal line it's not exactly
there but that's almost what it is if
I'm trying to draw my light cone okay in
both directions it's almost just a
horizontal line this is what light is
doing and that's my future light cone
this is my past light cone which is
doing almost exactly the same thing
right I'm Way exaggerating the
difference here just so you can see it
in truth it would be infinitesimal will
be less than a pixel you wouldn't be
able to perceive it at all so this is
the light cone in human units meters and
seconds coming from this point and look
it looks almost like a surface it
doesn't look like a huge
three-dimensional region of space or
four-dimensional region of space it just
looks like a moment it looks almost like
a sheet of simultaneity and this is what
we in our everyday life call the nap
if you extend the now from here meters
away you're fine you're moving and your
experience in life is so slow compared
to the speed of light that for all
intents and purposes there is something
called what's happening simultaneously
to you a few meters away it's only if
you're moving close to the speed of
light or if you're talking about things
that happen light-years away or
something like that that the structure
of relativity really becomes obvious and
important and inevitable okay that was
one point to make here's another point
to make spacetime is a wonderful example
of unification we went from two
different notions space and time and we
combined them into something called
space-time and this is something that
happens over and over again in physics
in the history of physics where you have
things that looked like that they were
separate but you can really find a
common origin for them both you unify
them it happens so often it's so
wonderful when it does happen that
sometimes we talk about you know grand
unification in particle physics or the
theory of everything but you know we
don't know ahead of time what the
ultimate theory is going to be like I
would I would think that probably the
ultimate theory will have even more
unification than we have now but
remember we have to actually look at
what nature does not what we want it to
do however space-time is a wonderful
example of unification so it's not just
that space and time themselves are
unified but a whole bunch of other
things get unified at the same time so
let's as it were
so let's I'm gonna you know be bad be
typical be standard and draw my
space-time diagrams with X's and T's
because that's what people do and that
helps us understand so let's consider
some moving particle I don't know why my
path gets little bumps in it like that
but okay so here's a moving particle and
it has a velocity right but you got to
think carefully about this in fact what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw a
separate diagram oops
this is a spacetime diagram as we've
been drawing I'm gonna draw a separate
diagram for space okay so this is
space-time let's just draw our more
traditional space diagram x and y and we
might draw here's know light cones like
thinking my curve can go up and down at
all of it once if it's going through x
and y it's not a spacetime diagram I can
have a velocity right here's a trying my
best to draw a little arrow here
velocity equals it's a vector it's the
derivative as you know of the position X
with respect to time and so velocity is
a vector what does that mean we put a
little arrow over it and it has
components there's a velocity in the X
direction there's a velocity in the Y
Direction is a velocity in the Z
direction if we're in three-dimensional
space and okay it makes sense what is
the velocity is the rate at which we are
moving through space as a function of
time what about space time you know
we're moving through both space and time
and the idea of a rate at which we move
through space time is a little bit
different because time is passing
inevitably right like in space maybe
your trajectory is just you're just
sitting there you're not moving at all
in space-time you inevitably move in
some way even if it's just forward in
time so in some sense the rate at which
you move through space time is always
one it is always one second per second
but that's just a limited sense because
of course we can still compare the clock
reading that we have when we carry along
with us to this time coordinate and that
will change as we move and so forth so
what we do is we define something called
the four velocity this is the three
dimensional velocity so this is the MU
where the MU is a Greek letter it's a
it's an index the MU has components the
T for time V X V Y Z it's supposed to be
a capital D I know this is capital B for
space time little
the I know you can tell the difference
but they're different trust me and what
they are every single one is just the
derivative with respect to the time
elapsed for you the proper time is it's
called a relativity the time on your
watch of the coordinate X mu which is X
here is X Y Z and this is X zero is
called time so in other words this is a
little bit more than you need to know
for this level of understanding but
everything we did in Google three
dimensional geometry has an analogue in
four-dimensional space-time geometry we
put time as the zeroth dimension why do
we do that
probably because we very often will
imagine more than three dimensions of
space or less than three dimensions of
space but we almost always have one
dimension of time so if you made time
the fourth dimension and counter your
dimensions zero one two three four four
time then when someone wants to come
along and do 10 dimensional string
theory they're gonna have to boot time
to be the tenth dimension or something
like that
it's more convenient just to keep time
as the zeroth dimension and have as many
number of spatial dimensions as you want
okay fine that all fits together very
nicely but the reason why I'm saying
this is because we have momentum and
momentum in good old Newtonian mechanics
it was a vector it was the mass times
the velocity we have a four momentum in
space-time and it is called P mu and it
is M times V mu and it has it has
components there's a momentum P zero in
the time direction px py PZ and the
miracle the reason why I'm going through
all this effort is p0 is the energy and
then px py PZ is just a three
dimensional momentum so the point of
this is that not only our space and time
unified together but energy and momentum
are you
together energy is the time version of
momentum now proving this to you I'm
just stating it but this is one of the
beautiful aspects of relativity that
these things that were separate in
Newtonian mechanics become unified in
relativity and that's just a very
beautiful aspect of it okay and let me
let me wind down a little bit with
matching this on two other ways that you
might have been already exposed to of
thinking about relativity so if you're
ordinarily taught by a regular person
relativity you will be taught a lot
about length contraction length
contraction and time dilation or the
other is the other thing the time
dilation we secretly already talked
about right we talked about the
different amounts of time passed by a
twin and who stayed behind in twin who
went away length contraction is the
other thing you're going to think about
in the conventional ways of doing
relativity and the reason why I don't
like this sort of way of introducing
relativity as much is because we talk
about time dilation length contraction
like it or not you're still stuck in the
Newtonian viewpoint that says that
there's something called length and
there's something called time separately
you're not really diving in to the
waters of special relativity where all
there is is space-time and the speed of
light you're still dividing up
space-time into space and time by
talking about length and by talking
about time separately and that's exactly
what gets you into trouble so
nevertheless you can talk about them
here's how we would draw the phenomenon
of length contraction so length
contraction is if you told in when you
are exposed to special relativity things
moving close to the speed of light
contract they get shorter they seem
smaller what does that mean what is that
about so I would not like you to think
of it that way I would like you to think
of the fact that things exist in space
time not just in space so if we can
idealize a little rod like the pencil if
we can idealize it as one-dimensional in
space okay so we ignore the thickness of
it we just focus on the one dimension of
space then in space-time it is
two-dimensional
so a one-dimensional a one-dimensional
rod in space is two-dimensional in
space-time so on my picture how would I
draw this rod well it has a beginning
point and an end point and then they
persist through time right both forward
and backward for that matter and so let
me see if I can do this correctly I
tried to set this up and not perfectly
correctly but I'm trying to draw in fill
in in between this is supposed to be the
extent of the little rod okay
and you ask yourself well what is the
length of the rod and what you mean is
usually you would sort of draw some line
in space-time and you could measure its
length that's something that exists and
call that L but notice that you made a
choice right you made a choice of which
way which line along which to draw from
the left side the beginning of the rod
to the right side to the end of it I
could have drawn the line this way
called that now or let's call it L prime
just to be special okay and I would have
gotten a different answer right because
we know the the formula l squared equals
x squared minus T squared and so if I
drew it with some extent in time in
other words if I measured the beginning
of the rod and the end of rod at two
different moments of time then I would
have gotten a different length for it
and in fact you know this line that we
drew right here looks longer on the way
that I drew it but we know that it
actually has an extension time so it's
actually shorter in space-time interval
and therefore it is in fact contracted
that is the origin of length contraction
okay
length contraction comes from the fact
that the way that we drew it in the rest
frame of the object is the longest
possible length that we could have
associated with this
the what I would like is to live in a
world where we don't associate lengths
with things at all we can talk about the
length of something in its rest frame
that's okay we're allowed to talk about
it but if you want to think about it if
you really want to get the intuition
right it's better to think about the
whole two-dimensional extent and in the
same vein you know there's something
that we often hear talked about in
discussions of special relativity which
are frames of reference okay
so I will connect my way of doing it
with the traditional way of doing it and
then tell you why I don't like it I
don't love don't love it it's fine but I
don't love it so here's what I mean
your spacetime diagram X T we can think
of these X and T coordinates as being
associated with a particular observer
what I mean by that is let's imagine
here we have a person and they are
starting here and they just stay
stationary they don't do anything in
other words they just stay at x equals
zero okay and what that person does
imaginarily not really but we assume
that they could do this is to send out
little rocket ships infinitely fast okay
breaking the speed of light and they
move at you know perpendicularly so they
send out little rocket ships that go
this way so what they do is essentially
construct a coordinate system all
throughout space time because these
rocket ships carry clocks with them and
so they can measure not just the
distance perpendicular to how this
person is moving but also the time you
could also measure the time going up
okay and so this is how you would
construct a coordinate system all
throughout space time based on what is
seen by this observer and just by the
way I'm saying it is obviously not
something that would ever actually
happen that would never actually be done
but you it's something you can imagine
doing but then you could say oops I
don't want to do it that way then let's
say we do the same thing but from the
perspective of a different
observer so I'll write my original X&Y
coordinates here but let's imagine that
my observer is moving at some velocity
okay and they define x equals constant
to be where they are okay and T which
we'll call t coops I said that was why
that was not right so this is supposed
to be T the same time coordinate but our
new observer locates their center of
time at themselves so that's T and you
can say well if they were to send out
rocket ships infinitely fast where would
they go and their reference frame and
the answer is if you if you know that
the speed of light defines a light cone
at 45 degrees so this is C speed of
light then the rocket ships would do
something like this so they would not
and you might think that's a little bit
weird because this what I'm doing here
is very very analogous to rotating
coordinates in good old Euclidean
geometry right we have x and y and we
can just rotate coordinates to x prime y
prime but usually that's fine but
usually what we want to do is keep them
perpendicular to each other okay and you
might say well here the yellow lines I
drew this does not look perpendicular
that doesn't look perpendicular at all
that's at some angle but remember the
minus sign that is in Minkowski in
geometry it turns out that these lines
really are perpendicular to each other
in the Minkowski and sense and so this
is the new X prime coordinate and this
is the new T prime coordinate and
they're at this angle than what remains
fixed is the speed of light the light
cones remain fixed because the light
cones are what is built into space-time
in this way of thinking about things so
what happens because of this is very
interesting because I can I'm gonna use
more and more colors this is awesome so
let's imagine an event here
and an event here B okay so you notice
that to the first observer in that is
say in the coordinates of the first
observer which is just the white labeled
X and T a happens before B there's space
like separated so in some sense you
shouldn't compare them timewise but in
this coordinate system in this frame of
reference a happens before B to the
second observer in other words in the
yellow coordinates B is before and
because B is under that little first
line that we drew okay the yellow line
so what happens before what is not the
same two different observers in
different reference frames if those two
things are so far away from each other
that there's space like separated so
something can happen right now right
here in your room and you say well
there's another event at Alpha Centauri
4 light-years away what is happening at
the same time the answer is there's no
such thing as at the same time there's
at the same time in a reference frame in
a coordinate system that is setup
relative to an observer but that's your
choice that is not built in to the
framework of the universe
now the reason I don't like talking this
way is because what I would rather do
instead I would rather just think
locally in other words rather than being
an observer who stretches out a
coordinate system all across the
universe I'd rather just say what is it
that one observer sees so there's this
temptation relativity to talk about you
know how fast is a clock ticking from
your point of view when you're far away
but it's out there moving close to the
speed of light or when it's near a black
hole or something like that I wouldn't
just uh nask that question I want to
just say
you can ask questions about what you see
coming from that clock what the reading
is that you get from light rays going
from the clock to you or you could ask
about what a person standing next to the
clock sees and the answers are different
okay because you're they're doing
different things in space-time but the
short answer to the second question what
is the person standing next to the clock
see they will always see a clock moving
at one second per second that's why
because not only are they moving
differently or they different different
gravitational field but the clock is
also and they're being affected in
exactly the same way and the whole point
of relativity is to them they're not
being affected at all everything is
perfectly normal from their point of
view so rather than saying clocks move
faster when they are stationary or when
they are far away from gravity or
something like that or saying the clocks
slow down when gravity is strong or
they're moving close to the speed of
light I like to say the clocks move at
one second per second all the time but
what you can do is compare clocks when
they leave you and then they come back
and they're back at the same point in
space one of the reasons why I'd like to
emphasize this perspective is because it
extends very naturally to general
relativity well we've been talking about
so far is just special relativity we're
not gonna do generality completely right
now that's for a future video but the
punchline the general point oops
of general relativity is that space-time
still exists still crucial but now
space-time is curved it has a geometry
and that's not such a surprising thing
maybe you know if we go way way back to
the beginning here and we talked about
where to go yeah we talked about Euclid
versus Minkowski we are talking about
geometry this is what is going on
space-time has a geometry there's a way
of talking about it at the simple level
of Euclid versus Minkowski the only
difference is a minus sign okay there's
all plus signs in Pythagoras's theorem
there's a minus sign that appears in the
medical skiing way of doing things
general relativity is going to guess
what general
is this it's going to say that this the
difference in geometries could be much
more dramatic and because of that this
trick over here of having an observer
and extending uniquely a reference frame
all throughout the universe is not going
to work they will in generally general
not be possible to do that
so in special relativity different
observers might attach different notions
of simultaneity very far away in general
typically you can't even do that in
generality there's no way to attach a
notion of simultaneity generally there
can be special cases but in general in
the most generic case you just not gonna
be able to do that at all rather you
should think locally you should ask what
individual observers actually experience
and let me just mention that let me just
emphasize one one feature here
all of this general relativity and
special relativity or these are part of
classical mechanics so special
relativity yeah I was not very beautiful
special relativity is the theory of a
fixed background space-time and the
particulars of it is the speed of light
is invariant that latter fact speed of
light being invariant is still true in
general relativity but special
relativity is an arena on top of which
other theories happen electromagnetism
quantum electromagnetism etc there are
relativistic theories theories that play
in the playground called special
relativity whereas general relativity is
a theory by itself that is all
playground because it says that
space-time is not fixed space-time is
dynamical it responds
to matter in energy and we observe we
feel we interpret the curvature of
space-time as gravity that's what
gravity is according to special to
general tivity is the curvature of
space-time
so despite special and relative in
general being the terms here general
relativity is more general than special
relativity because it allows for not
just flat space-time geometry but for
arbitrary space-time geometry but at the
same time general relativity is a
specific theory Einstein made a specific
choice for the equations of motion of
the gravitational field of the curvature
of space-time and those define what we
mean by general relativity so both of
these are by themselves classical
theories in the sense in the following
sense they're not Newtonian they're not
absolute space and absolute time but
they can fit perfectly naturally into
the Newtonian laplacian paradigm in both
special relativity or general relativity
you give me some positions you give me
some momenta I have equations that will
let me chunk forward in time and figure
out where the particles or where the
fields are going to be next it's quantum
mechanics where things really become
different so some people put the
difference between classical physics and
the rest of the world at both relativity
and quantum mechanics they group
together relatively in quantum mechanics
as post-classical
I think that's not the best way to do it
these are words they're arbitrary we can
make them up however we want but I think
that it's better it's more productive to
associate quantumness with the departure
from classical physics relativity is
great spacetime is great it's still the
classical world so maybe next time we
could think a little bit more about the
quantum world